Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Um, I don't know why I feel so nervous, even though, like, I sort of, you know, the video's over already.
But it's like, it's my first year anniversary!
For, like, the third time!
How many anniversaries does she need?!
How many first-year anniversaries does she have?!
Thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you!
Happy Jiro day, Doki, and also y'all Dragoons!
Yes, you're sitting here with me today, because it's not only my anniversary, it is also your anniversary, too.
To be fair, we do have a Dragoon day, but, like, it's alright.
We have two, and the next, and then, like, this is next week, and next week is Dad's birthday, too.
So, it's not Valentine's Day, it's more important than that.
It's Doki Amber Doge's, um, um, birthday as well next week.
Sorry, my throat is dying.
Um, yesterday I couldn't talk at all.
Like, I am really nervous, because, like, I'm, like, really paranoid that I'm gonna go through the three-month period of, like, coughing again.
So, I'm, like, really paranoid right now about that shit.
But, like, yesterday I had to rest a lot, because I legitimately couldn't talk at all yesterday.
So, I hope today will be okay for me.
I hope, I hope I'll be okay today.
Um, um, Joel, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Anniversary Akasupa!
Happy anniversary from this, um, UFO Dragoon!
Thanks Doki and Mint for the song!
For another 365 days!
Thank you, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you all so much for the superchats, everybody.
Um, yeah, I know I was like, guys, don't...
Uh, guys, I don't know if I have anything to reveal.
I was so busy the last couple of...
Not even the last couple of months.
The last year?
I feel like I've been non-stop.
Gas, gas, gas, gas, gas.
And then, like, I went on vacation.
And I went to Japan.
Cause I was like, I need a break.
And then, like, so then I was like, I'm not gonna think about the anniversary.
Even though technically I had nothing planned for the anniversary.
Just a huge shoutout to the music video team.
Um, for finishing it up in time for the anniversary.
Um, they worked incredibly hard to make sure it was done by today.
Um, this has been in the works for a while.
As you guys know, it was shown in our very first concert.
Um, at AnyRevel.
And, um, the team has been working incredibly hard.
It was actually originally slated for a Christmas release.
This was gonna be a video that was gonna play on Christmas.
Uh, but obviously there were some delays for it.
Uh, in a way where, like, we couldn't, uh, have it out by Christmas.
Um, and that was the thing I had planned.
That was the video that I had planned for Christmas.
But luckily, we were able to make it in time for the anniversary.
I was like, oh thank God, I do have something to show.
Like...
I do, I do have something to show to people.
But I do have a couple of announcements.
A couple, I'm really sorry for your wallets.
Um, I'll be straight up right now.
This might not be a good month for the Dragoons wallets.
But to be fair, I didn't have a lot of merch coming out in a while.
So, like, you guys must have saved some money, right?
For this exact moment, you know?
For this...
For this moment, right guys?
You guys must have saved the money.
About all the merch I didn't release.
For this exact moment, right guys?
Right?
No...
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, guys.
Alright, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy anniversary, Doki.
Here's a hongbao for my forever Kamiyoshi.
I can't believe a year has come and gone.
I'm so proud of everything you've done this past year.
I'm looking forward to many more.
We'll always be by your side no matter what.
Thank you for your Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Also, um...
Let me, uh...
Let me screenshot.
I'm gonna screenshot from the video the credits for all the people who worked incredibly hard on the...
I do have a couple of announcements as we go along.
There are a couple of announcements.
A couple of merch announcements.
A couple of other stuff announcements.
So, like, don't go because there's a lot of stuff to talk about.
And then you guys are like, Doki, you fucking liar.
You said there was nothing.
Okay, I do have some stuff, okay, guys?
Doesn't mean I have nothing.
I do have some things to show you guys.
I just didn't go all out.
Like, I, you know, I didn't have time.
I had too many things going on.
Too many fires to put out.
So, I couldn't actually go all out.
So, like, this is me going, like, um...
Going average.
Like...
This is me going average instead of going all out.
So, um, anyway.
Um, because it's gonna be launching in literally eight minutes.
I will show you guys the very first merchandise drop for my anniversary.
So, um, well, okay.
Sorry, I don't know why I'm super nervous.
It's like...
I don't know why.
I've been doing this for so long.
And I'm still like...
I don't know.
I still have butterflies in my stomach for some reason.
Anyway.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wow.
All right.
Let me grab the image.
I'm sorry, Dragoon.
We're gonna cover you up real quick.
All right.
So, it's gonna launch in seven minutes.
But the very first merchandise drop is...
I will be doing an official collaboration with Gina Draws.
If you guys don't recognize Gina Draws, she's actually a Dragoon and runs a very successful own shop.
And with my collaboration with Gina Draws, we will have...
This is just one of a big collection.
But we're releasing this early just for the anniversary.
So, we have a pajama set and an eye mask.
And if you buy the set together, you'll get a freebie sticker.
Yeah!
I love the eye mask.
The eye mask is so good.
So, this is the first anniversary...
One of the other merch drops that's gonna be coming out today.
So, this is releasing on Gina's website.
In approximately six minutes at 5.30 PM PST.
So, let me show you the other pictures that I was...
Oops, that's not it.
I almost attached something else early.
So, here is more details.
So, there's pajama set.
It goes from small to 3XL.
And then there's the eye mask.
And then there's an exclusive pre-order freebie.
So, pre-orders are expected to ship on May, June 2025.
So, it's gonna be on the GinaDraws.com website.
That's where you can start pre-ordering.
And you can follow Gina Draws for more updates regarding this.
The pre-orders actually end in two weeks, guys.
There is only two weeks to grab this merch.
So, this is limited edition.
It is specifically for a first anniversary.
So, yeah.
If you guys want the eye mask and the pajama set, make sure to grab them before it's gone.
And sadly, this is also one of the several merch teasers that I'll be posting.
So, I'm very sorry.
I'm very sorry for your wallet.
I'm so sorry.
But yes, Luna's so cute!
I was there to personally help with designing and giving my input on all of it.
I love them.
I love the eye mask so much.
It's actually so fucking cute.
I cannot get over the eye mask.
I really can't.
No, I just bought the dead drawing!
But yes, let me pin.
Also, sadly, my main manager is not available right now.
So, when I announce my other merch drop, I'm gonna have to do the shop myself.
So, like, this is gonna get a little scuffed.
Like, I'm nearly a one-man army right now.
Pre-order your pajama set here.
So, like, it's all over the place at the moment, really.
But yes, I'm sorry.
I'm just...
I think it's also because I'm sick, too.
So, my brain is extra fried.
I just bought the plushie, Doki!
Okay, I might as well announce this one, too.
If you just bought the plushie, I'm so sorry.
Doki, what do you mean by that?
Doki, what do you mean by, I'm so sorry?
Um...
But I will... I know I should be like, you know, Doki, you need to, like, you know, tease them out longer.
I...
Guys, um...
Um...
It's not... It's not this month.
I'll let you guys know right now.
It is not this month.
What I'm about to tease right now is not this month.
So, you have time.
You have time.
But I'm very sorry for your future, Dragoons.
I'm very...
Oh, man.
I see everybody suggesting things.
And you're all right.
Because...
No!
Okay.
So...
All right.
Okay.
So...
As you can see...
Whoa, what could they be?
I wonder.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck could all of these be?
These won't be this month.
I'll let you guys know right now.
These are not available this month.
But...
They might be soon.
So, this is a little teaser for all of you guys.
For what's gonna be happening in the future.
So...
So, I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry my anniversary is around tax season.
Okay?
I'm sorry.
I know.
The timing couldn't be more fucked up.
Um...
Uh-huh.
GK, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, sweet.
New Doki bird merch.
Puts it next to Marvel merch.
Leaves room, but returns.
Okay, down.
Hey, what happened to all my raccoon...
Rocket raccoon?
Black Panther and me and stuff.
They're destroyed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As God intended.
As God...
Blake, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
All right.
Anyway.
That's not all.
But I'm not gonna announce the next thing yet.
Because, like...
Um...
Obviously...
Blake...
It's not...
It's...
It's gonna...
It's gonna be wild.
Oh, yeah.
I believe...
Let me see if the drop has happened yet.
Because it was supposed to be at...
Oh, there it is!
If you refresh the website!
It's up!
Oh, my God!
There it is.
I see it.
If you refresh the website right now...
Um...
The Doki Bird pajama set is now up, guys.
Yay!
Let's go!
All right.
So, yeah!
Let me talk about the...
Okay.
So...
Um...
I'm really proud of the 3D team for working incredibly hard on doing everything.
Like, I want to sincerely apologize to the 3D team.
Because sometimes I was just not reachable.
Because I was so busy.
And then they would have to send me, like, several messages to be like, Hey, Doki!
Yeah, we sort of need you to approve stuff.
And I was like, I'm sorry.
I'm a mess right now.
I'm so sorry.
But, like, I'm glad they understand.
Like, in the future...
Okay, so, like, these are how my future projects are now set.
Because, sadly...
Not sadly, but the...
No matter what MV was, like, just solely done by me.
Like, not done by me, but, like...
I was, like, the main point of contact.
But, in the...
Like, my newer projects...
I have delegated to my staff.
And then, so, like, if they can't reach me...
If they can't reach me, my staff...
They'll reach out to my staff member.
And then my staff member will yell at me every day until I...
No, I don't cry.
And then they'll be like, If you don't work on this, I also stop working.
And I'll be like, no, don't stop working!
I'll get on to it, I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I would get, like...
I'd get, like, lectured by my manager.
Like, what are you...
Work on this!
I'm like, okay, I'm sorry, I will!
I'm sorry!
Please don't stop working!
But it's very motivating.
It's...
Like, my manager has been...
Like, my staff and my manager has been, like, my motivation to, like...
To, like, not slack off.
And I really appreciate it.
Gina, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
There she is!
Happy Doki Day!
So proud and honored to be a dragon!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much, Gina.
It was great working with you.
And I cannot wait to showcase the rest of the collection in the future!
Doki, what do you mean, the rest of the collection?
Well...
I told you, this year, we're gonna be...
We're gonna be fix...
We are gonna fix our merch issue and actually have merch come out.
So, last year, we might have, you know...
It was a bit of a mess last...
Okay, I'm not gonna lie, it was not a bit...
It was sort of a huge mess last year.
We're still fixing things, but, like, things are...
You know, people are getting, receiving their stuff now.
But, like...
But, like, this year, we fixed a lot of what was not working.
And because of that, we're able to actually...
We can actually have, like, merch for you guys.
Official merch and stuff.
Things I've always wanted to do and everything.
So, yeah, I'm super excited.
I'm really happy that we're actually making progress and everything.
Oh, yes!
Let me grab a screenshot of...
Let me grab a screenshot of the credits.
Because I want to show you guys, like, all the people that worked on it.
I'm super excited.
I'm super happy with the team.
You might see some familiar faces on the team.
And some people who are new as well.
So, it was funny because, like...
I love, like, discovering...
I don't know if discovering is the right word.
But I love, like, finding new people to work with.
And, like, you guys know how I usually...
Usually, how I find people is just...
Okay, so, like, my Twitter for you page is so good.
It's, like, works really well for me.
Because, like, that's how I find, like, artists and animators and stuff.
And I also, like...
A lot of, like, very talented animators and artists that have done, like, fan art and stuff for VTubers as well.
And everything.
So, it really is very helpful.
Like, being able to, like, see stuff like that.
By the way!
If you guys didn't know...
If you guys didn't notice...
So, like, here are all the talented people that worked on the video.
So, you can see some familiar names and some new people.
That's been...
Some familiar names of people that I've always worked with a lot for 3D things.
And...
And some newer names that you might not have seen them before.
Someone was like, Jimmy!
We have our animator, Chilifish.
Is...
Actually, English is not their first language.
So, we had Jimmy help translate some of the instructions and stuff like that to help Chilifish, who was our main animator.
Huge shoutout to Chilifish.
They are a very talented animator.
They've done a lot of stuff.
I need you guys to know...
Chilifish animated all of these.
I think on a laptop.
I'm pretty sure.
It was a laptop or, like, not the very best PC.
So, it was insane.
The things they were able to do.
I think it was.
I might be spreading misinformation.
Let me double check real quick.
Yes.
Okay.
Chilifish animated all of the video on a laptop.
Isn't that fucking insane?
This person is so talented.
Like, just imagine what Chilifish could do on an actual PC.
Like...
I was very impressed.
Yeah.
So, huge shoutout to the animator.
You might recognize Jules, who's been our project lead for a lot of 3D projects.
Because they're very well-versed in project management.
And have done a lot of management for me for project management for a few things.
And Yuni for the concept art, the backgrounds.
Nem for the motion graphics.
And, like, some of the 3D props, 3D graphics.
We had a storyboard artist.
We had a lot of people going in, helping out and everything.
And, like, Resurq, Squid, SaltedFish, Plixer.
A lot of them helping in with a lot of the stuff that took to make this video.
And, like I said, huge shoutout to all of them for working incredibly hard.
Because it's been a work in progress for a while now.
So, I'm really excited that we actually were able to release the video to you guys on an anniversary.
Like, you know, on a special day and everything.
So, I'm, like, I'm muting my coughs because that's not hot.
Other announcements.
If you guys didn't know already, if you guys didn't see on Twitter.
I know some of you guys don't want to go on Twitter anymore.
Which is very understandable.
Like, I'm terminally online.
So, like, that's not the case for me.
I get my misinformation and news on Twitter.
Which is basically the same thing.
So, like, I have to be on Twitter.
And also, like, you know, I am a quote-unquote influencer.
So, I do have to be, sadly, I do have to be on Twitter.
Even though I'm not as active as, like, you know.
I lurk.
I am a lurker.
I've always been a lurker.
And it's very hard to not be a lurker.
Anyway, so, if you guys didn't know.
For those who don't go on Twitter anymore.
I have an official plushie now.
Yeah!
So, good smile.
The people who made our Nendoroid.
They reached out to me.
Like, during all the pre-orders were happening.
That they wanted to make an official plushie for me.
And I was so surprised.
Because I was like, oh my god.
Like, you know, I didn't expect them to also offer this as well.
So, I was very excited to work with Good Smile.
To, you know, make me a marketable plushie.
Like, an official plushie from Good Smile in general.
Is actually insane to think about.
And I, you know, I was very honored.
I got to pick between if I wanted Retro Doki.
Or, you know, Bounty Hunter Doki.
And I decided to do Bounty Hunter.
Because I was like, you know what?
You know, we already have Retro Doki as an android.
I want something newer for the Bounty Hunter Doki.
Because, you know, Bounty Hunter Doki doesn't really have a lot of merch as yet.
Like, official merch.
So, I was like, let's go with Bounty Hunter Doki.
And then we can have Doki Amber Doge with me too.
Like, the fact that he's on my head and everything.
So, yeah.
It's actually, you can pre-order it right now.
Either on the Good Smile website.
Or on other websites like AmiAmi and everything.
So, yeah.
This is another announcement I wanted to make.
And...
Fuck, I didn't mean myself.
I'm so sorry.
So...
That is another announcement.
I still have several more announcements and everything.
But first off, let's just, you know...
I don't want to, like, fucking throw everything at you guys.
I don't want to be like, and there's more!
And then just keep chucking more and more stuff at you guys.
And be like, please.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna be over stuff.
And then I'm gonna fucking explode.
Like...
I'm sorry.
I might have, like, overfed my dragoons today.
But also, like, sold their money too.
I might have, like, overfed you guys so you can't run.
And then I'd be like, here's your wallet.
Please.
That's right.
I feed you guys so much you can't run away.
Make it fast for my wallet.
Don't let it suffer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, if you guys didn't know...
I have released the 3D Chibi model of the Bounty Hunter model now.
So you can download.
Yes, I've been holding on to this Chibi model for so long.
Because I was gonna release it.
I was gonna release it when the video was out.
And now that it's finally out, I can finally release the Chibi model.
So you can go to my Sketchfab.
My mod can link that right now for me.
You can go to my Sketchfab and, of course, you can use it however you like.
As long as, like, you know, you don't do anything, like...
Like, I don't wanna say stupid.
You can do stupid things with it.
But, you know, like, nothing illegal.
That's all.
Nothing illegal, please.
And no, like, I don't know.
You know the rules.
You know the fucking rules.
Like, I don't have to repeat them or anything.
But yes, you can now download this model for free on Sketchfab.
For any use you want with it.
Well, I shouldn't say any.
With restrictions.
Any use you want with it, with restrictions.
You know the rules.
But yes, that's another announcement right there.
Also, I usually do this for all my MVs.
But, like, for the member goons.
So, I'll be posting a tweet.
English is hard right now.
I'll be posting a tweet after the stream.
Asking which screenshot, which, like, image, still image, you would like to have on No Matter What as a wallpaper.
And then I'll be putting, zipping all of that.
And then posting it in memberships.
So, this is something that I do for memberships if I release any MVs or anything.
So, member goons will have access to the wallpapers of, like, still frames of No Matter What, the MV.
So, I'll be tweeting about it.
Be like, oh, which image do you want to have as a wallpaper?
And then I'll be grabbing all the images and stuff.
And then putting it, um, and then putting it as, like, you know, putting it in members.
So, you have to be a member, you have to be a member to be able to access the wallpapers itself.
Uh, and also we have other wallpapers too, that you can, there's a lot of wallpapers and stuff, uh, for people, um, in the memberships.
And it's not, there's not just, like, you know, the MVs, there's, like, other illustration wallpapers.
I usually give free wallpapers every month.
Except for this month, because, like, no, except for, no, we have a Valentine's wallpaper coming out this month.
But we didn't have one for January because I fucked up.
Um, so we're having two wallpapers in March, I think.
It was either March or May, I don't remember.
I have a lot of things going on, I stopped remembering things now.
I legitimately, I, I stopped, I, like, you know, you're, like, you have too much information, so you start deleting things that don't matter.
So, like, I don't remember people's last names anymore.
Like, I, I legitimately, like, there's, like, information that I've, like, stopped keeping track of.
It's just, like, not important enough anymore.
Not, like, your name's not important anymore to me.
And, so, I just, like, it's like a hard drive, and now I'm just, like, delete them right now.
So, um, anyway, yeah, so, like, that's how my life's going so far.
And then, like, I, I, I don't, okay, sometimes I don't even remember what's gonna happen next month anymore.
I mean, like, my staff keeps track of, like, all my oblig- you know, like, when conventions announce that I'm gonna be guesting there?
And I was, like, oh, fuck, wait, am I?
I, I, I, but they do the announcement.
I was, like, oh, my God, I'm doing that?
Whoa, that's a surprise for me, too.
Because I forgot.
Because, like, usually conventions, they reach out really early on.
Um, they reach out super early on and stuff.
So, like, my staff would be, like, do you wanna do this?
And I was, like, sure.
And then a couple- and then I forget, you know?
I just say yes, sign the contract, and then, like, I forget about it.
Because I was, like, there's so many things going on!
And then, and then, like, you know, they announce it, and then my staff would be, like, we need you to retweet this.
And I was, like, wait, oh, my God, I'm going to Australia?
Let's go!
And then, I'm pretty sure I'm going to forget about it within, like, because the Australia one is, like, what?
It's, like, at May or something?
Or April?
And then I'm going to- it's going to be, like, May?
And then my staff's going to be, like, remember, you have a convention in two weeks!
I was, like, I have a convention in two weeks?
Yeah, it's an announcement for me as well.
Certified Toki moment.
More falls, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I'll be, like, I usually, you know, I plan things weekly and stuff.
So, yeah, no, my staff has a calendar for all my official events that I sign contracts for.
And then, yeah, I literally, they just be, like, do you want to do this?
And then I'll be, like, yeah, sure.
But, like, sometimes- okay, so, last year, this was an issue last year.
By the way, thank you guys so much for the insane support.
Thank you for companies, for conventions, like, all the insane support and, like, things they want to do with me and stuff like that.
And, like, I had an issue last year where I said yes to a lot of things.
And then my calendar was so fucking stuffed.
And even my staff was, like, I don't care, you sure?
And I'll be, like, yeah, sure, what's the problem?
Yeah, sure, like, it's only a couple months, like, I don't have to worry about it later on.
And then, you know, a couple months later, it happens.
And then I find out I have to do three conventions within one month.
And then I was, like, oh, man, why didn't anybody stop me?
And my staff would be, like, we did.
We told you it might be too many.
And then I'd be, like, oh, man, fuck.
And then, so, like, this year, I also really wanted to meet as many Dragoons as possible.
But last year, I learned what my limits are.
And, like, because I was, like, I never get a chance to do any of these before.
Oh, my God, I'm so excited.
I never got to meet so many Dragoons in so many different parts of the world.
I want to do it all.
And then, like, last year, I learned my limits.
I was, like, it was great.
I had a great time meeting so many Dragoons and everything.
But I definitely might have overextended myself.
Like...
I for sure overextended.
So this year, this year, I told my staff.
I was, like, okay, like, I'm going to forget about this.
But I need you guys to make remember this for me.
And, like, make sure I don't book, like, three plus conventions in one month.
And also, maybe, like, you know, stagger these conventions too.
I don't know.
Seems like good advice.
And if I try to be, like, no, I can do this.
Stop me.
I was, like, if I, for some fucking reason, feel like I'm, like, invincible.
And, like, I can do it all.
Stop me.
Because I know I'm not now.
Don't let future Doki ruin this for me.
So...
Yeah, so...
I was, like, make sure I don't do this.
Don't do that.
But that's basically how it's been going so far.
I can stop any...
I cannot.
I cannot stop anytime.
I, like, I wish I could.
I really do wish I had that much power.
But yes, happy one year.
It's crazy.
I feel like it has not felt like one year.
I'm not gonna lie, Dragons.
It really does not feel like one year at all.
This has been the fastest year it's been.
I feel like I just spend run my entire career within that one year.
It doesn't feel real.
It does not feel real at all.
And, you know, obviously there's a lot of things I would love to do.
But I also feel like I've done so many things I didn't think I could ever do, too.
And, like, a lot of, like, these brand deals and people who noticed me and stuff like that.
And I can't believe I had a video hit a million views and it wasn't even on my channel.
I hear you, Motoki.
You've had, like, a livestream hit a million views.
Okay, but I haven't had a video hit it.
Okay, so for those who don't know, um, Kony made a video about the whole Marvel Rivals, Twitch Rivals thing.
And it went viral.
And I was the one that told her, I was like, just use, you can use me as clickbait.
And, like, you can, like, just, like, be as go-fucking-unfiltered as possible.
Cause Kony was like, should I restrain myself?
Like, should I do-restrain myself?
Do you think this is too much?
I legitimately said, it's not too much, you should go harder.
So, you're welcome, Kony.
Anyway, that video got a million views within a week, by the way.
Um, so, like, I think I went viral again.
How many times do I have to, it's actually crazy.
I feel like within that year, I have went viral so many times within, like, the normie sphere.
Like, I don't know what is up with my luck and, like, being, like, making, like, I don't even have to try anymore.
I just, I just stumbled onto it every time.
Like, it's just, it's just like, I just stumbled onto, like, I'm like the third wheel of virals.
Like, every time I go viral, it's because I'm like a third wheel just observing something that happens.
And it just happens, I just happen to be, like, sort of involved.
Like, so, so, like, also, like, but then for some reason, despite going viral, I'm still incredibly unlucky.
I feel like I got sick, I got food poisoning.
Um, I, I, like, um, I had, like, a very weird trip in Japan.
Like, I talked to you guys about, oh my god, about some, like, the weird shit that was, like, going on in Japan and stuff.
And, uh, yeah, it just, they're like, you can have a good life on the internet, but fuck you in real life.
Oh my god, um, but it's actually, it's actually fucking wild.
I, I, I can't even name, I can't even, like, list, I mean, I did list all the stuff that, like, has happened within the year.
But it's still a lot of stuff that's happened.
And then, like, you know, I became one of the top VTubers for Marvel Rivals 2, which is really crazy to think about.
Because I never thought that I'd be, like, even though I sort of stopped, oh, I sort of stopped, like, streaming.
It's, right, Marvel Rivals, because, you know, I have to catch up on a lot of things, too.
Like, I can't really, also, like, our, my relationship with Twitch is, like, it's on, it's complicated right now.
It's...
I'm at a, it's complicated at the moment, so...
So, that's why I haven't been streaming Marvel Rivals.
And, like, also, it's actually crazy.
When I queue rank in Marvel Rivals, so many people, like, recognize me, too.
Like, high ELO players recognize me.
Not just, like, pro players, but other high ELO players.
But then, like, either they shit talk me or they, like, wish me good luck or be like, I'm a fan.
And I'm like, but then, like, the people that shit talk me, I'm like, what did I do to you?
Like, I was like, I'll be like, we're winning!
Like...
So...
So, like, it's weird.
It's such a weird scenario to be in.
But, yeah, so there's a lot of those things going on and everything.
And, oh my god, it's just, like, obviously, I couldn't do it without you guys.
You guys, like, helped me get to, like, this point of my life.
I'm still a mess.
I'm still, I'm still, I'm not gonna lie, I'm still a mess right now.
There's, like, so many things to fix still.
Like, running my own, like, you know, business is incredibly hard.
I'm scared of taxes right now.
I'm...
I'm really scared.
You know, taxes before were a lot easier to do.
But, like, taxes now, I'm fucking ner... I'm scared.
By the way...
By the way, guys...
Oh, shit, ow, sorry.
Oh, yeah, so, like, another fucked up thing that happened to me in Japan, by the way, is that I got an infection on my finger.
And I've never got an infection on my finger before.
So, like, I, so, like, like, it was, like, on the side of my finger.
And then there was, like, and then it was, like, swollen and it hurt for, like, for, like, three, three plus days.
And you know when the infection stopped?
When I got home.
So...
So, like, fuck me, I guess.
No, it's gone now, it's better.
It was, like, it was just, like, um, it was just, like, a small infection and stuff.
It was just literally, like, a small infection on the side of my finger.
Like, cause, like, the crease between the nail and the finger.
I don't know how, I've never had that happen before.
I don't know.
I think Japan, I don't know, maybe I'm cursed in Japan.
After everything I've been through, like, um, my body is rejecting it now.
Like, my body is just, it was just, like, trauma for my body.
It was so weird.
I was just, like, how the fu- I've never had that happen before.
It is actually...
It is actually crazy.
Like, I've never got food.
The last time I got food poisoning was when I was a child.
And then, like, and then I got an infection on my finger.
And then I got a cold on the last day.
Like, my body was, like, just, I don't know, like, I guess you're gonna die.
It's just, like, happy one year anniversary.
Okay, sorry, that got a little dark.
Sorry, that was dark humor.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, it was actually, my body was just giving up in general.
I still love Japan.
I think, like...
I think if I ever go back to Sapporo, it'd be in the summer.
I'm sorry.
I know, you're like, Toki, Sapporo's known for their snow.
But, like, I'm reminded because, like, I'm reminded of why I hate snow.
Like, it's because, like, I grew up...
I grew up with snow and I always hated snow.
And then, so, like, I was just like, oh, man, how bad could Sapporo be?
I'm used to snow.
But then I remembered, like, Sapporo snow is a lot harsher than where I live.
So I was like, oh, man, I hated snow before.
But, like, now I'm reminded of why I hate so much snow.
Yeah, it's very pretty.
I would admit it is incredibly gorgeous.
But I would rather, like, see how pretty it is inside.
I would look at the window and be like, wow, that's beautiful.
And I'd go out and I'd be like, I guess, like, I hate myself.
So, like, but it is beautiful and I love the food there.
I still don't know what got me fucked up, what I ate there that got me incredibly fucked up.
But I still, I still enjoyed my time there.
Despite, like, everything wrong that happened to my body.
And, like, in general, everything wrong that happened to me in general.
Also, I forgot to mention, but no matter what the cover song, the cover song with Mint, it is not monetized.
Like, because obviously it's an English song.
Like, I'm pretty sure, like, to get an English song monetized, you gotta go through a lot of...
I gotta pay a lot of money to Cartoon Network.
So, like, you know, the rights and stuff to, like, get that video monetized.
And also, like, I don't think a record label would wanna talk to me anyway.
So, like, it's not monetized at all.
But, like, still support the video.
Or, like, if you wanna support the video, I guess watch...
If you wanna watch, like, give me ad revenue on No Matter What.
Just have a stream play in the background, I guess.
Or donate, yeah.
Or super chat, yeah.
Ad revenue.
I think it's easier to just have one stream play in the background to make up for the no ad revenue on No Matter What.
Cartoon Network is bankrupt, I thought.
Yeah, that's why they're taking my monetization on that money.
That's why they took it off.
They took the monetization off of that video.
Why else do you think they need it?
Mr. Orange, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You should go to a SEA country next time.
If you hate snow, it'll make you hate high heat and humidity a lot more.
No, I hate that too.
I hate, like, going to, like, anywhere that has, like, a lot of humidity and incredibly hot during the summer.
Which is why I also avoid that as well.
So that you go to those places during the winter, and then you go to, like, places that are super cold during the summer.
And then that's the perfect vacation for me.
That's why I stay indoors more.
I remember when, like I said, when I first, like, when I first, like, came over to, flew over to China for the first time.
You know, I was born in Canada.
And I flew over, I couldn't breathe.
Because we also went over during the summer.
And I couldn't fucking breathe because of the humidity.
Like, I was not, because in Canada, it's, like, super dry.
But, like, you know, from a dry place to, like, incredibly humid place was so fucked up for me.
It was, I was not ready.
And apparently, my blood is very tasty for mosquitoes too.
So, like, you know, you know, it was a big wake-up call for me in general, for, like, Little Doki in general.
Because I was, like, mosquitoes are, like, she doesn't, oh my god, a child that doesn't have any mosquito repellent.
And is wearing short, like, you know, short sleeves and shorts because she doesn't know better.
And, yeah, like, I was practically feeding the homeless mosquitoes, you know.
Zero defenses going in.
So, like, you know, it was not the best of times for Little Doki there.
It's literally, like, I won't be surprised if mosquitoes start camping out of airports.
Because they know, they knew this is where all the ignorant, ignorant visitors come from.
But, yeah, that's basically how it went.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, he's back.
Doki Amber Doge is back right now.
He's just relaxing on his bed.
The moment he came, okay, like, I'm pretty sure, like, he's counting the days till he goes back to the babysitter.
Because, like, she spoils him so fucking much.
Like, I got given daily, like, dad photos.
And then, like, every time I see that, I'm just, like, calm.
And I don't know if he wants to come home.
I don't know.
Like, every time I see those photos, he's just, you know, he looks at her with so much love in his eyes.
I'm like, when have you ever looked at me like that?
It's been so long since you looked at me like that.
And then, dad would be like, it's not my fault you're focusing on your career.
When have you shown me that love before?
It's not my fault you just focus on your career.
He's like, I need some affection too.
So, like, I think he's cheating on me.
Trouble in paradise.
Doki, what?
The new hit drama coming in.
Cas, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
This super chat is monetized.
Happy anniversary, Doki.
Thanks for... Yeah, I think he's sulking.
I don't think he's sleeping.
Now that you say it, he might be.
Oh yeah, I'm paying for his affair too, by the way.
Like, shit, I didn't even think about that.
I'm literally paying for him to have an affair.
The rest of my money will go to Doki, much fun, and Isu.
Thank you for the Akasupa, Cas.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, this little fucker right here.
Okay, I'm cutting him off.
That's right.
This little fucker right here.
He's having an affair and all I can do is work so I can pay for it even more.
Alright.
Teach dad a lesson by turning him into a plush.
My girl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like, okay, so...
And like, the thing is, the babysitter carries him around all the time.
And I'm like, what?
But like, I don't do that.
Because like, when I picked up dad, the babysitter came up, like you know, was holding him.
And then walked up to me and was like, do you want to carry him or leave him on the floor?
And I was like, no, put him on the ground.
Yeah, because like, basically she would like carry him everywhere and stuff.
Like, so he doesn't have to walk, you know, like a fucking peasant, I guess.
Like, it wasn't even that far from me.
Like, that's the thing.
I was like, why are you carrying him?
But like, yeah, he's spoiled, spoiled, apparently.
So like, she like, got off her car and carried him to me.
And then was like, do you want me to put, do you want to carry him?
Or like, put him on the floor.
I was like, put him on the fucking floor.
And then the moment he got on the floor, he was just like, I hate you.
He's like, he's like, now it's over.
It's over.
Why won't you carry me like her?
I don't want him to become an overweight wiener dog.
That's also one of the things.
Guys, the worst thing you can have is a fat wiener dog, guys.
It's actually terrible because it's not healthy for them.
I don't want him to become a fat wiener dog.
Like, it's bad for them because they're too long.
It's bad for their back, guys.
I'm trying not to make him fat.
So he can live a longer life.
He'll understand when he's older.
I'm a great parent.
You know, like how moms are like, you'll understand when you're older.
And that's what I'm doing to my dog right now.
Anyway, I bought him a little hat in Japan.
And then I like, told my friends.
And my friends were like, oh, he's gonna hate that.
And I'm like, I know.
But it's gonna look so cute.
It's like those little winter hats, but for dogs.
But yes, I bought him a little.
I bought him a little.
I'll show you guys later.
I have so much photos I want to show you guys.
But I won't do that on another stream because I won't focus on, you know, anniversary.
But there's so many.
I'll do that on the next stream.
Because I have, also like, I haven't prepped any of my photos yet.
So, literally like, yesterday was spent.
Yesterday was spent recovering and also prepping something.
Prepping like, announcements and stuff for today.
And then the day before yesterday, I had that Marvel Rivals tournament.
Which I went 1-9.
But like, it was stacked against me anyway.
And then after that, I played rank.
Because I was like, I want to win in something, you know.
I don't... I'm already depressed.
At least let me get top 500.
I did beat Shroud, xQc, and Tariq though.
The only team I did beat was xQc, Shroud, and Tariq.
So like, I feel like that's already...
That's, you know, I'm happy about that.
The only game that actually mattered in the end.
No, it was like, duos.
Yeah, it's basically like 9 wins, if you think about it.
That is enough for me.
And then, you know, the day before that...
I was also recovering from coming back from Japan.
And then I had to like, remember how to play Marvel Rivals.
Because I literally didn't play the game in 2 weeks.
So then, it was literally... I just had no rest.
By the way, speaking of no rest.
I will most likely cancel tomorrow's stream.
Because...
By the way, guys.
Most likely, I will be canceling tomorrow's stream.
Because like, I had a talk with my manager.
Like, today and yesterday.
And my manager was like, you have so much shit you have to do.
Like, as in like, you know, not angry.
Okay, a little angry.
I'm like, a little angry.
But like, you know, tough love.
You know like, you have a lot of stuff you need to do.
And then I was like, I know, I'm sorry.
I know.
I'm sorry.
I know, I'm sorry.
I was playing Marvel Rivals.
I'm sorry.
And they're like, they're just like, you know, I let it go pass by.
Because you're having a moment there.
You are not okay.
But like, you need a...
You cannot run away with Marvel Rivals anymore.
And I was like, I'm sorry.
Do you want me to help get you to...
Because like, they also play Marvel Rivals.
And they're like, you also...
But I was like, I'm so sorry.
Anyway, I can help you get to Celestia tonight if you want.
I can get a friend to help out too.
I legitimately was like, I'm so sorry.
But tomorrow, I'll work on it tomorrow.
But also, this is really private.
And then my manager was like, oh, maybe.
I mean, if you have time.
If you have time, yeah, maybe.
If your friends can help me out to get to Celestia.
I'll be like, oh, yes, it worked.
Yes, it worked.
It fucking worked.
I don't give her an excuse, manager.
Yay!
Anyway, so I actually have another announcement that I want to give you guys.
Because the video just finished editing.
I hope it...
Honestly, I'm watching this for the first time too.
I've been watching this video for the first time as well.
So I hope everything goes well for this video.
Alright, guys.
So I have another announcement.
My stalling worked.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but I'm a professional.
And that was actually me trying to stall.
But I do have another announcement for all of you guys.
And I'm going to be watching this live with you guys too.
So I have no idea how it's going to really go.
The moment I'm putting this video up right now too.
Okay, so.
Three.
Are you guys ready for the announcement?
Are you guys ready?
This is not the last announcement, by the way.
This might be the second last announcement.
Three.
Two.
One.
After a
long wait since that concert.
I can finally announce something.
That everyone has been waiting for.
The most polygons you've ever seen.
A debut that's been anticipated for years.
My official 3D debut.
With special guests.
Special performances.
Special everything.
And the debut is...
Right now!
It's finally here.
Look, dragons.
I'm 3D now.
Look at these movements.
That new 5090 RTX.
On is hitting hard.
Wait.
Is this not the Doki you wanted?
I mean, you can't get any more 3D than this.
I told you.
Anime girls are real.
Come on, look at these close-ups.
Wow.
Look at this.
And this.
It looks like real leather.
Wait, I know.
You're expecting something else, right?
Okay, fine, fine.
I guess you dragons deserve a real 3D debut.
It is my one-year anniversary.
Now...
What you're actually waiting for.
My real 3D debut.
That's right.
It's me.
Retro Doki.
Man, 3D graphics go hard now.
What?
This is not the 3D debut you're looking for?
But it looks and feels so real.
I mean, if you zoom in...
You might even see some of my pores.
Oh, I see.
You wanted me in something else, right?
Like her?
Hey, dragons.
Is this the 3D Doki you wanted?
I mean...
I am the best Doki that everyone wants to see.
All Doki is best girl.
Just like Cathy.
Okay, okay.
Enough of her.
We don't want you to forget about me.
Look.
I'm fucking with you guys.
Okay?
I know what you're here for.
Here is the real 3D debut.
It doesn't get more 3D than this.
That's right.
My true form.
Tomato Doki Bird.
What do you think?
Yeah.
I grew a little bit bigger than a regular tomato.
I think a year ago, I was this size.
Alright, alright, dragons.
No more baiting.
I'm not gonna bait anymore.
Are you guys ready?
In 3, 2, 1.
My real 3D debut.
Here I am.
The real Doki.
I mean, what gets realer than this?
Well, I hope you guys enjoyed my 3D debut.
Thank you.
Happy one year anniversary, dragons.
Thank you everybody for coming to my first year anniversary since I came back.
Surprise.
I guess that's all I had planned.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
There's more announcements later.
Cock cock.
Kuroky out.
Bye.
Sorry.
There's no actual 3D debut.
That was just the longest bait and switch I've ever done.
Bye bye.
Also, here's me with a cowboy hat.
Yeehaw.
Cock cock.
Alright, bye.
I fly away now.
That's basically it.
There's no 3D debut.
It's not scheduled yet.
I have zero plans for it yet.
Okay, huge shoutout to everybody that worked on that.
Because that was done in 24 hours.
I got the idea.
I got the idea this last, like, yesterday morning.
Huge shoutout to all the cosplayers.
To all the cosplayers.
To the video editor.
And the crows.
Sorry, to me.
Huge shoutout to me for all of that.
I was like, can you guys actually do this?
And they're like, yeah, no, we can film it.
I literally wrote the script.
And then a huge shoutout to the editor, too, for putting this all together.
I was just like, oh man.
My real 3D debut.
Thank you, me, me, and me.
Thank you to all the dookie birds that helped out.
I would say thank you to...
Alright, let me grab the people.
Oh my gosh, I'm on streamer mode, so I can't even grab their...
Alright, let me write their Twitter handles real quick, guys.
Huge shoutout especially to the editor.
Alright, so this is the editor.
Huge shoutout to them.
They fucking crushed it editing this.
I watched that live.
I gave her all the clips.
All the clips, all the videos.
I was like, go wild.
Do whatever you can before it just...
I don't know what's gonna happen, but do whatever you can to put all of this together.
Here's my fucking wild idea.
If you can do this, I'd be so impressed.
I could've added DookField, too.
But then, like, that's already too much work.
That was too much work.
So, yes.
That was gonna be my only plan.
Not gonna lie.
That was actually gonna be, like...
Might've been, like, the only thing I was gonna show today.
But then the fact that we managed to get the music video done as well.
So I was like, oh, we have multiple things I can fuck around with.
You know, I have...
There's, like, multiple things I could do.
Thank God.
Let me do the font real quick for everybody.
Alright.
And then...
Okay, here we go.
Alright, so, this is the editor.
Huge shoutout to the editor.
And then I'll show you guys all the cosplayers and everything, too.
Alright, so huge shoutout to the editor for...
Imagine the last announcement is actually the 3D.
And you guys should know, I have not contacted any studios yet regarding my 3D.
So...
It's gonna be a wave.
I just thought it'd be fun.
Because I know some people are like, oh my gosh, she's gonna announce her 3D debut date.
And I was like, oh, but what if I did?
What if...
I was like, oh, man.
But what if I did announce it?
Oh, man.
Alright, so here is all the other cosplayers.
Like I said, please check them out.
The fact that they were able to get all of this...
Like, film all of that for me within a day was crazy.
I was not expecting them to be able to...
I just was not expecting that to work.
I was gonna be like, whatever cosplayer I could get...
The fact that all the cosplayers I contacted were free to do this...
I really appreciate that.
Like, I was not expecting it, so...
Thank God it worked out.
Thank fucking God it worked out in the end.
Alright, so here's the other one.
And then...
Let me grab the tomato and...
Let's see, this one was...
The other cosplayer.
And her child.
Her child was...
These are all their Twitter handles.
And her child.
So, these are everybody that was...
And...
Wait, what is it?
Crows.
Biggest credit to the child.
Yeah, so...
Shoutout to...
Shoutout to all the cosplayers and the editor...
For doing all that for me.
I really, really appreciate it.
I was like...
Like, you know, the biggest bait and switch I've ever done.
I don't know if I will upload the video itself, but...
Maybe I should, it's pretty funny.
Maybe I should upload the video, it's pretty fucking silly.
I liked how I was looking at the view count...
And it kept going up because people actually thought it was real.
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Like, it jumped like 1.5k.
And I was like, oh man, people really thought it was real.
Oh no.
I was like, oh man.
People were like, oh man, surely this will be the actual announcement.
And I was like, psych.
And then I was like, peace out, I'm flying away now.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna fly away now, peace.
Yeah, got me on the first part.
Yeah, so they were all cosplayers.
Really big thank you to all the cosplayers for doing this.
Since like, legitimately this morning.
Last night, not last night.
Yesterday morning was when I had this idea.
And then I was like, I don't know.
I don't know if like, I could do it.
So I asked all these people.
And then they're all like, yeah, we can do this.
We can make this happen.
And I was like, oh my god.
And then like, huge, biggest shout out to the editor too.
For putting all this together.
The fact that I didn't...
That she managed to make all of that into a coherent fucking video.
Fucking insane.
It looked amazing.
I was watching that for the first time too.
Oh, and the animator.
Oh my god, sorry.
Croaky animators.
Sorry, Croaky looked so real.
That like, I almost forgot that hat isn't real.
Sorry, sorry.
The animator that drew a hat on those crows.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot to talk about the animator that gave them hats.
I felt so immersed that I legitimately like, forgot that it wasn't real.
Wait, the hat wasn't real?
What else wasn't real?
But anyway, also huge shout out to the animator.
For animating the hats.
Alright, here we go.
YinMelonSoup was in charge of the crows.
But my immersion...
What do you mean it wasn't real?
I thought Croaky was the most realest one of them all.
I'm so sorry.
I know, it was just too good to be true.
It's real to me.
It's real.
But yes, huge shout out to YinMelonSoup.
For drawing, giving the crows hats.
For the immersion.
Alright, final announcement.
Final announcement of the night.
So, I'm sorry to your wallets again.
But, I am announcing a special, special, special thing.
On my own store.
Which I have to open myself.
So, it's gonna be wild.
But, the Doki Day Anniversary Limited Edition Voice Pack.
So, it's very limited.
There's only a select number.
Basically, there will be a select number of stock.
That's gonna be on the store.
Regarding custom voice pack.
And a digitally autographed and numbered wallpaper.
By my mama.
Kamame.
So, I will be opening this on the merch store myself.
Like, in a couple of...
But, there will be regular sale of the wallpaper.
It just won't be...
There just won't be a custom voice pack.
Or like, it won't be signed or anything.
So, there will be a general sale for the wallpaper.
Plus all the ringtone, alarm, and anniversary voice pack.
That will be like $5.
But then, the other one is $100.
I'm sorry.
The general voice pack is normal price.
The general voice pack will be there forever.
The limited one, it was not sold out.
It will go until February 28th.
And basically, like I said.
For the custom voice pack, plus the digital autograph.
And the digital autograph and numbers.
You can do anything with the wallpaper, by the way.
If you want to print the things out and stuff.
And...
Basically...
Oh my gosh, what was I going to say?
The staff will be emailing the members.
The staff will be...
Honestly, I could just make it...
I feel like $100 is a little too much.
I mean, I'm the boss.
I'll make it $50.
Because there's so much stuff that you can buy.
The best part about being my own boss is that...
I put $100 because I based it off previous knowledge about this.
And I feel like there's a lot of...
There's a lot...
Just like that.
Because I was the one that came up with this merch.
And it's all digital.
So...
Doki...
The thing is, I have a lot of merch stuff going on.
I feel bad.
I feel...
I feel so bad.
Because there's so much other merch stuff.
How about this?
We'll go in the...
How about $75?
$100 with 50% off.
What a deal.
Yeah, because I feel like I have so much stuff coming out as well.
I'll do $75.
I'm fine with $75.
We'll go in the middle.
We'll do $75.
Make it $200.
Okay, so...
There will be a general sell.
And then you don't have to know what message you want.
I think it's within 100 words.
Basically, it's within 100 words.
Oh, you're right.
I can make it $69.
You know what?
I'm going to make it $69.
Wait, no, man.
That's actually...
That's good.
Let's make it $69.
That's better.
$69.69.
Yeah.
Fucking taxes are going to be weird, but...
Let's do it.
It's going to be $69.69.
$69.69.
And...
The script has to be within 100 words.
And you don't have to know what the script is instantly.
You can just purchase it now.
And then get...
My staff will email you guys.
My staff will email you guys on like...
You know, what you want.
And stuff like that.
And then, you know, you've done it before.
And you sort of know how it goes.
So that's basically it.
Alright, let me do the store now.
Guys, I have to like redo the...
Oh my gosh, my manager is going to fucking yell at me.
He's going to be like, what do you mean you changed the price last minute?
Well, you should have been awake.
It's not my fault.
You should have been awake.
I would have randomly just changed the price if you weren't awake.
Okay, $69.69.
There we go.
That's right.
I have to open the store up myself.
You can't blame them for sleeping.
Okay, alright.
Alright, in three...
Oh wait, you guys don't even see it right away.
Because I have to do the banners.
I have to put the banners on to myself.
But like, it's active now.
Like...
Let me put up the other one.
The other one is $5.
This is the most professional...
Merch is up now.
Fucking stream ever.
Guys, I'm not...
I don't know if I'm good at this.
I don't know if I'm good at doing this.
By the way, it's up now.
If you go to jokeymerch.com...
You can see it's up now.
Alright, jokeymerch.com.
Oh, it's not even...
Guys, I don't know if I'm good at being a streamer anymore.
I'm not...
Alright, here we go.
It should be...
69.69.
There we go.
I hope the limit is still working.
But that should be everything.
Let me do the...
Oh yeah, he even gave me like...
A step-by-step guide on how to do this.
Because I never had to do this myself.
Oh my god, how do I do this?
He sent me screenshots and everything too.
He was like...
Here's the instructions...
On how to add sliders.
And I was like, oh my god.
I have to do this myself.
And then...
They were like, that's your own fault.
You didn't have to do this yourself.
Wait, is it already sold out?
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I'm sorry, I can't add more inventory.
My manager would yell at me.
Because he didn't trust me.
Sorry.
We have regular voice pack.
We have the regular one, guys.
I'm so sorry.
He doesn't trust me.
He was like, we're adding this amount.
I don't trust you.
And I was like, okay.
I'm sorry, guys.
I would add more if I could.
But I don't want him to be mad.
I don't want him to be mad at me.
Okay.
Let me get the product in.
Of the other voice pack.
Where is it?
Okay, there you go.
Yay!
Did it work?
Is it up on the site?
I did it.
I put it up myself.
Is it up there?
Oh my god.
There was an error.
Wait, is it?
Did I fix it?
What happened to this?
Oh, no.
I fucked it up.
Don't tell him.
I fucked up the store.
Oh, no.
What did I do to the store?
Don't tell him.
I'm gonna fix it.
Why?
Why is there a fucked up URL?
Where is that?
What is that?
Is it this?
Oh, it was this, right?
Why is it like that?
Guys, don't tell him.
Shh, it's our little secret.
Shh.
That's why your manager doesn't trust you.
What he doesn't know won't hurt him.
Okay, I fixed it.
I fixed it, guys.
I did it.
There we go.
Did it actually already sold out?
That's crazy.
Alright.
If I can somehow convince my manager that I am a responsible adult, maybe he'll let me add more inventory later.
But for now, I can't because he might yell at me.
If we do add more inventory, I'll let you know.
Because he's like, I don't even trust you to get that X amount.
What if I just add one more?
Guys, how would he know?
I'm gonna add one more, guys.
What if I just add one more?
You know what?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna add one more.
He won't know.
How is he gonna know?
Mods, do not snitch me out, mods.
I swear to god.
Don't do it.
Don't snitch me out.
How do I do it?
I don't know how to add one more.
Okay.
One.
I added one more, guys.
I did it.
Guys, I did it.
I added one more.
I'll just be like, oops.
Don't freak us.
Guys, mods, come on.
Don't snitch me out to the head honcho.
Guys, oh my god, it's already gone?
Holy shit.
Okay, we do have the regular ones, though.
We have the regular pack.
Guys, I can't.
Guys, I need to be able to convince my manager that I can...
I don't know if I can.
I'm sorry.
I'm scared.
Today, he was like...
He was like, we are not adding more.
But I was like, I can do it.
I swear.
I could swear I could do it.
And then he was like...
He was like, I don't believe you anymore.
So I can't.
I can't add another.
I cannot.
I cannot add more.
I cannot do it.
Anyway...
He's a real friend.
So... Okay, but what if I add one more?
Okay, I'm gonna add another one.
I'll do two more.
Okay, guys.
Two more.
I'll just be like...
Two more, guys.
Two more.
It'll be fine.
This is the last one.
This is the last one, guys.
Two more is the last one.
Two more.
It's like plus three.
Guys, it's plus three.
What's the worst that could happen?
I did it.
I added two more.
Don't snitch on me!
He's not gonna have... No!
He doesn't have access to the analytics of the store.
My store manager has the analytics of the store.
So, like, she won't snitch on me.
Because I pay her too.
She's not even awake, right?
She might be awake.
She's not watching the stream right now so she doesn't know the details of this.
Because I only told the details to my main manager, but the store manager she doesn't know.
She was in charge of shipping some of the old stuff, so she doesn't know.
So she's the only one that has access to that.
So, she's not gonna snitch on me.
Yeah, but he's not gonna count 50.
He's not... Yeah, alright.
Okay, no more.
No more, guys.
I can't.
I can't, guys.
We already went beyond my limits.
No, we do not snitch here!
This is a safe zone!
This is a... He's asleep!
He's not gonna know!
He's asleep!
This is my safe place right now!
Guys, this is my safe place!
Guys, please!
He's not awake!
This is my safe space!
You don't even know how to contact my manager!
You don't even know!
He's not gonna know!
I'll just be like...
Oh, man!
My chat kept begging me!
And like...
You know I'm so easily persuadable!
And I'm gonna blame you guys!
If you tell him, I'm gonna throw you under the bus!
Because you threw me under the bus!
That's fucking right!
You think I won't do it?
I'll throw you under the bus with me!
I...
She has a point!
You wouldn't!
That's fucking right!
I'll pin you down with me!
Yes!
Uno mas 10, please!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
We all go down together!
Yeah, that's fucking right!
I ain't going down by alone!
Alright!
Don't threaten me with a good time!
Alright, that was fucking...
That was a wild...
It's been fucking wild, honestly!
I had a great time!
Oh, my God!
Did you guys see?
There's a teaser!
You guys made so much amazing content for me!
Like, fanart, music...
Did you guys see a sneak peek of a game that people were working on?
Did you guys see that?
I was like, holy shit!
Okay, wait.
I need to show you guys.
Where was it?
It was on Doki Day.
Somebody made, like, a Bomberman!
It's making a Bomberman game!
I was like, holy fuck!
That's so cool!
I was like, I'm so excited to play!
I fucking love Bomberman!
I wish, like, you know, the actual Bomberman game's netcode isn't fucking bad, but, like, dog shit, but, like, other than that...
Yeah!
I'm trying to find it.
There's a lot of tweets here, so, like, I'm really bad at this.
But, like, I'm bad at a lot of things.
Oh, here it is, guys!
Look at this!
No, right?
It's actually been a year.
It's actually crazy.
Look at this!
It's so cool!
I'm so excited!
I'm actually really excited for this.
I fucking love Bomberman, but I feel like a lot of the recent Bomberman games, the, like, the netcode is so bad that you can't even, like, play Bomberman online very well.
So, like, yeah!
It looks really, really, really cool.
I'm super excited.
There's so much amazing artwork and everything.
Guys, thank you, guys.
I know I don't thank like, personal thank yous on Twitter and stuff.
I'm really sorry to all the creative people that support me with their amazing artwork and, like, music, games, and everything.
Like, um, I'm so bad at, like, replying to people, especially, like, even people I know.
Like, I personally know I'm really bad at replying to people on Twitter because, like, I'm so used to being a lurker for a majority of my life.
That is so hard.
Like, and also, like, when I'm really busy, like, I just don't, I just, like, don't message people.
Like, I like talking to people.
I don't, like, I don't know.
I like talking to people, like, vocally versus, like, messages.
Um, I'll give an example.
So, like, um, Ray messaged me about something, like, I was, like, in Valkyrie, uh, to, like, apologize about, like, how, like, the Twitch Rivals thing was going on, and I didn't reply.
I didn't reply back for, like, a week plus because, like, I had to plan my Japan trip.
I was like, it's not your fault.
It was Twitch's fault.
I was like, no, bro, like, I'm not, like, like, like, no, I don't blame you.
It was, like, it was Twitch that, like, all the stuff that happened, like, they shouldn't have done all the change, real change.
And she was, like, and then the thing is, I didn't reply back within a week plus because I had to do my Japan trip and I was, like, planning for that and I was, like, so overwhelmed with everything and then after Japan trip was over, like, I replied back and then she was,
like, oh my god, I thought you hated me and then I was, like, oh, no, I'm sorry.
I legit, like, legit, I just, I'm just really bad at messaging people.
I'm so...
I was, like, I don't hate you.
Like, like, don't keep on ghosting Valkyrie and I'm, like, I'm sorry.
It's not you.
I do this to everybody.
I felt so bad.
I was, like, I just, like, I'll reply to her tomorrow and it never happened until I came back from Japan.
That's why I'm really, I'm really sorry that, like, I'm so bad at communicating.
I have really bad communication skills.
Also, I forgot to say, huge shout out to Sirius DV for doing the subtitles for No Matter What.
If you guys checked theirs, I want, if you guys want to translate this, if you guys have, like, the translated lyrics of the song in other languages, please let me know.
Feel free to link it and, like, add me on Twitter and then, like, you know, if it's in Japanese or Chinese or, like, Spanish or anything, I can have the subtitle person to make subtitles for it, closed captioning for other languages for those who want it.
Obviously, I do need the official lyrics for it.
I don't even know what, I don't know where to get the official lyrics for the other, for because it isn't an actual song and I'm pretty sure there is official lyrics for it.
So, like, if anybody has, like, a link to the actual official lyrics, like, just feel free to send it to me and then I can have it put as a subtitle.
But, yes, thank you for all the Akasupas and all those superchats and, in general, and all the memberships and everybody and subscribing.
Rosie, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for being here, Doki.
Here's to another great year.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, there were so many announcements.
I still don't think I had a lot of stuff going on for, like, this today's stream, but...
But I'm glad a lot of you guys had a great time with watching and hanging out with me today for this year.
But it's really been a wild fucking year.
We had so many announcements.
We had so many merch announcements in general.
Like, other than, like, you know, the wallpaper, the official wallpaper, and the custom voice packs.
That's already sold.
I can't, guys.
I cannot add more inventory.
I'm so sorry.
I don't want to get yelled at.
I really...
I really don't.
And then the official Gina Draws uh... Gina Draws pajama set with the eye mask.
And then we have the uh... and then we have this that's coming out soon but not this month, so you guys don't have to worry.
And then we have uh... this that is officially out on GoodSmile website.
And then... oh yes!
I saw the trophy too!
There were so many cool things!
And then we also have, you know, we also have the... this model that's out now, right now, that you can download.
Um...
and then we also have uh... haha.
Oh yeah, let me check.
People made, like, the official trophy.
It looks so cool!
Um... yeah, I saw it.
I was like, oh my god.
Oh my god.
You guys are all so talented.
It's actually crazy how talented you are.
Uh... and then we have the cover song of With Mint, the No Matter What.
Like I said, I chose that song because I felt a deep connection to that song in general.
Um, because I felt like it really reflected how that year was like.
Well, not the year, but you know, the events leading to that year.
It really felt like it...
um...
um... it really it felt like, uh...
you know, a lot of stuff happened that the events leading to it and it really connected well to me and you know, the events afterwards and I'm just happy to actually cover this song.
I'm really happy that this was a song that I was able to sing and that Mint really wanted to sing that song with me.
Um, but yes.
What a year.
What a fucking year.
Yeah.
And then also the bait and switch video that I did for you guys.
Uh...
Um...
But yeah, it was...
Is this where I get the voice back?
Voice back!
Don't go!
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Oh no, he's coping.
He's coping.
He's like, please, please, just one more.
He's not gonna know.
I won't tell him.
Just add one more doggy.
He's not gonna know.
He's gonna know!
Guys, I have... He's gonna know.
I can't!
Thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you, thank you.
It was a perfect song choice.
I'm so happy you guys sing it together.
What a year.
Thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you, thank you.
He's gonna know.
I can't, guys!
I already added three!
I can't!
But yes, what a fucking wild year.
But like I said, I'm happy to spend that insanely wild year with you guys.
I said a lot in that voice back too.
I might repeat what I just said in that voice back.
Guys, I can't keep bribing him with Marvel Rivals, guys.
I can't!
I can't, like...
I can't keep... I can't!
Guys, there's a limit to how much Marvel Rivals rank I can give him.
There's a limit...
But it was...
Like I said, I wouldn't be able to do all of this without your support and everything.
I hope we can do get a million subscribers by the end of this year.
That is my biggest goal.
I really wish... love to get a million subscribers by the end of this year.
And I really want to achieve much, much...
many, many, many more things with you guys.
And continue doing content creation with my dragoons, if you think about it.
I've been doing this for a while now.
And I'm still... I'm always worried I'm gonna run out of ideas one day.
But for now, I'm still chugging along.
But thank you everybody.
I'm just thinking like, oh man.
I know I could say more but I feel like I said so much more already.
But thank you dragoons and thank you for everything.
And I hope you guys had a great time celebrating my anniversary... our anniversary.
It's not even mine.
It's our anniversary.
Together.
And I guess to like... I guess to end this whole thing...
Let's just watch that video.
I think it's a pretty funny video.
We could just...
I guess we end it off on the video and then we'll go to the ending screen.
Alright.
Alright guys.
Thank you as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!
Tomorrow's stream's cancelled.
Cause like...
I can't piss him off anymore.
So...
Thank you all for the superchats and the memberships and the subscribing and watching and like...
6 seasons and a movie.
I don't wanna say 10 more years.
I don't know guys.
I...
6 seasons and a movie.
Alright.
Finally!
After the long wait since that concert, I can finally announce something that everyone has been waiting for.
The most polygons you've ever seen!
A debut that's been anticipated for years!
My official 3D debut!
With special guests, special performances, special everything!
And the debut is...
right now!
Ha ha ha!
It's finally here!
Look, dragoons!
I'm 3D now!
Look at these movements!
Whoa!
That new 5090 RTX on is hitting hard.
Wait...
Is this not the Doki you wanted?
I mean, you can't get any more 3D than this.
I told you.
Anime girls are real.
Come on, look at these close-ups.
Whoa!
Look at this!
And this!
It looks like real leather!
Wait, I know.
You're expecting something else, right?
Okay, fine, fine.
I guess you dragoons deserve a real 3D debut.
It is my one-year anniversary.
Now, what you're actually waiting for, my real 3D debut!
Ha ha ha!
That's right!
It's me!
Retro Doki!
Man, 3D graphics go hard now.
What?
Is this not the 3D debut you're looking for?
But it looks and feels so real.
I mean, if you zoom in, you might even see some of my pores.
Oh, I see!
You wanted me in something else, right?
Like her?
Hey, dragoons, is this the 3D Doki you wanted?
I mean, I am the best Doki that everyone wants to see.
All Doki is best girl, just like Cathy.
Okay, okay, enough of her!
We don't want you to forget about me!
Look, I'm fucking with you guys, okay?
I know what you're here for.
Here is the real 3D debut!
Ha ha ha!
Doesn't get more 3D than this!
That's right!
My true form!
Tomato Doki bird!
What do you think?
Yeah?
I grew a little bit bigger than a regular tomato.
I think a year ago, I was this size.
Alright, alright, dragoons.
No more baiting.
I'm not gonna bait anymore.
Are you guys ready?
In three, two, one!
My real 3D debut!
Well, here I am, the real Doki.
I mean, what gets realer than this?
Well, I hope you guys enjoyed my 3D debut!
Happy one year anniversary, dragoons!
Caw caw!
Thank you, everybody, for coming to my first year anniversary since I came back.
Surprise!
I guess that's all I had planned.
I'm joking, I'm joking!
There's more announcements later!
Caw caw!
Croaky out!
Bye!
Sorry, there's no actual 3D debut.
That was just the longest beta switch I've ever done.
Bye bye!
Also, here's me with a cowboy hat!
Yeehaw!
Caw caw!
Alright, bye!
I fly away now.
Woo!